la comisión europea ha propuesto en
total la suspensión de 7.500 millones de
euros de fondos europeos a hungría por
vulneraciones al estado de derecho para
bruselas el gobierno húngaro no ha hecho
lo suficiente en cuestiones como por
ejemplo la lucha contra la corrupción o
el fraude en la contratación pública aún
así el gobierno húngaro se ha
comprometido a tomar las reformas
necesarias a aplicar 17 legislaciones
diferentes para que esta suspensión no
llegue a aplicarse nunca en cualquier
caso los estados miembros tienen la
última palabra tienen hasta 3 meses para
decidir pero en estos tres meses se
espera que hungría pueda aplicar estas
reformas y por lo tanto esta suspensión
no llega a ser efectiva aún así se trata
de un aviso muy claro por parte de
bruselas esta decisión se toma después
de años de tensiones entre bruselas y
hungría por vulneraciones el estado de
derecho como por ejemplo la lucha contra
la corrupción pero también la
persecución a las minorías a refugiados
a migrantes o incluso la presión a las
personas de la comunidad lgtb y
precisamente esta decisión se toma
cuando esta semana el parlamento europeo
ha votado en un informe en que considera
que hungría ya no es ahora mismo una
democracia precisamente por las
vulneraciones al estado de derecho